What if we have a multi multi-dimensional list
like a matrix? So one
of the things you need to know is when you have a list.
You can't put different data types.
It can have exactly can have different data types.
So for example if you have some sort of data.
You can have numbers in here.
You can have strings in here.
you can have
even lists within lists. Here's another list.
Okay, so you can do this.
Now how do we create a multi-dimensional data? So let's say here. We want to type in
products.
And imagine you're constructing a an Excel
sheet or what's what's what is
a composition of an Excel sheet rows of columns.
rows of columns
so we have the brand of the product.
some particular model they have
and the price of that product
so that's the first row. That's the second row.
And let's see. This is the third row.
so people Samson
All right.
If we take this entire.
lines of code
put them inside the list we have now created for
ourselves in metrics. So these are these are the columns.
And these are the rows and how do we how do we access the
price for?
the Samsung
you type in the name of the product. Excuse me type in the name of
the variable.
And you first go roll. So
the row here is 0 1 2.
Remember you have to count from 0, right? So
0 1 2 and then once we
are on the row we need to access the element.
from which we want to extract the value so 0 1 2
Okay, so this is a two-dimensional data, but
we can actually have three dimensional data now there is a special library
for working with.
a matrices and
the general type of a matrix called a tensor.
It's numpy, right?
And we will look at
examples of numpy as well. So what numpy you can have actually a
stack of matrices. So if this is one Matrix
You can have a stack of matrices, which is what we call a tensor. And of
course if you're into machine learning then
you need to know very well have numpy numpy works.
Okay, and if you've heard of pandas pandas
is built on top of numpy.
And we'll also look at examples of both of those libraries. I have a number
of slides ready.
That just that go into how a
numpy array object.
Works what are the properties of that particular
object and
how they work.
Okay.